هاتفك في خطر فهو معرض للاختراق اثناء
تناولك الشاي في المقهى من دون ان تعرف
مصدر الهجوم تحذير اطلقه خبراء في الامن
الالكتروني من طريقه جديده للقراصنه تعرف
باسم لمسه الشبح فيمكن للقراصنه او الهكز
من خلالها اختراق هاتفك والتحكم به لكن
كيف الهكرز يجهزون معدات خاصه تحت طاوله
الشخص المستهدف بحيث ترسل اشارات
كهرومغناطيسيه لمحاكاه النقرات على شاشه
تعمل باللمس بالتالي يمكنهم الوصول سرا
الى البيانات الشخصيه والرد على المكالمات
او حتى تثبيت تطبيقات ضاره الخبر الجيد ان
هذه التقنيه لا تعمل لمسافه ابعد من اربعه
سنتيمترات لكن هذا لا ينفي ضروره اخذ
الاحتياطات اللازمه لحمايه الهاتف كوضع
جدار امان واستخدام بصمات الوجه او
الاصابع